it's gone hey what up Theo this is Josh
and Emilio from pop el California we
have a serious question to ask you okay
this is Josh and Emilio from Palmdale
California and thank you guys for
calling these guys if you can't see them
on the video and your listener an audio
when I'm have short hair one of them
longer hair they look like they could be
in a band they also could be two dudes
at work at Quiznos but are the happiest
Quiznos workers you've ever met they
seem like joyous a young gent song word
so we were just talking about the woman
in Oklahoma who got mauled to death by
seven wiener dogs a couple weeks ago
whoo whoo and that's gang activity hmm
and you think here's the crazy thing you
think that had gone after somebody with
a wiener seven of them went after a lady
with no wiener
and that's reverse psychology and a lot
of animals we don't realize is you know
two animals they get together they might
have an idea
oh let's sneak out the doggie door three
animals maybe to be like Ollis you know
let's jump up on a cupboard and steal
grandma's chicken potpie for animals
they might be like ah you know let's
sneak out at night and get some [ __ ]
go five five animals get together five
wiener dogs get together and they may
like be like ah man this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
let's buy some peace stools you know
let's buy some guns you know let's buy
some let's buy some [ __ ] guns bro and
let's pop off baby but six dogs get the
other black oh you know that's embezzle
money let's build a YMCA and get
donations and [ __ ] take some money
out of their coffers you know we're sort
of us say we get in swimsuits for the
new YMCA swim team
but let's steal someone to add money but
seven animals get together and they
gonna prolly just take a [ __ ] down for
no reason what I'm saying is that's
groupthink that's dirty groupthink and
that's unnecessary man so if you see a
bunch of animals getting together and
you think it's
funny and [ __ ] like that and his Care
Bears and all of that maybe it's not you
know this ain't babe pig in the city and
other animals this is seven wiener dogs
getting who first of all who even less
seven wiener dogs get together and
didn't think something was happening
dude I never [ __ ] seen I've never seen
seven wiener dogs in the same state
before so you're telling me whoever
owned them didn't know that some kind of
[ __ ] was going on that other wiener dogs
are stopping by to visit their wiener
dog or they're all meeting up you go to
them you take your wiener dog to the
park and you know one week there's two
wiener dogs there and the next week
there's three and then a month later
there's four and then there's two you
know seven two of them two aren't on
leashes and you're like well you don't
notice something's [ __ ] going on
let's hear more I'm sorry for getting
upset thank you for bringing this to my
attention and we're it's not funny it's
not as a serious matter and when one of
the boys is laughing in the back and
this seemed like the boy this the
long-haired gentlemen homeward so
wondering how many wiener dogs do you
think you could take say if they were
attacking you like it took I think seven
to kill her how many things you take
before they ended up taking her life and
thank you for the question man I would
say four I feel comfortable saying I
would probably say three if I'd eaten
recently and I had a couple Gatorades or
something on a table nearby I would say
four but you think about do when it gets
up to five wiener dogs and a lot of guys
out there but like I could take all
seven no you couldn't know you couldn't
dude
because they had first of all a woman
couldn't take all seven and they got
some tough ladies out there so a man you
get a look and women are looked out for
women will fight to the end you know
five wiener dogs one of them's gonna
sneak you up and get you by the neck and
the hard part for some men is gonna be
feeling all that wiener against them and
that's the trick about a wiener dog is
you know they they get enough of that
body against you to feel like big
wieners hitting you and next thing you
know one of them get you right up in the
gullet and you necked out and you've
been Wiener it out but yeah I would say
four I think I could successfully defend
myself against four wiener dogs and look
I'm not trying to challenge any wiener
dog so if you out there if somebody's
out there caught up in the dark arts you
out there training WDS and your [ __ ]
basement and [ __ ] and you've got these
little things going through hoops and
eating heavy treats and stuff to make
their necks stronger don't come at me
with that [ __ ] I'm not trying to do any
of that I'm just saying I think I could
take four thank you for calling in I do
appreciate that man
I do appreciate well you know it's crazy
as my sister can't even read but what
does it have to do with us right now
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one